hey everyone it's Mike from water flows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for this video
where I'll be comparing my order flows
Trader software which runs on the
ninjatrader 8 platform to the volume
metric
Trader I guess it's called on
ninjatrader if you get the paid version
of ninjatrader you get access to their
volumetric charts which is their version
of the footprint because you know this
is a question I get a lot like why do I
need your software when a ninjatrader
already has a footprint on there and
you're going to see the main differences
and you know why I think my software
which is an add-on right takes the
footprint farther than a lot of the
Native footprint softwares out there
okay so this is you know my basic order
flow footprint chart right which shows
um the Delta the maximum Deltas Etc you
have
um the imbalances in the bar you have
point of controls all right so let's
open up a volume metric chart so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to open up
a new chart here again this is an e-mini
one minute chart so I'll just keep it
the same you got to go in if you have
the paid version of ninjatrader right
only on the paid version of ninjatrader
if you've got the free version you don't
have access to it so what you're going
to do is you're going to change it you
know from you know minute chart whatever
to volume metric so you're going to
scroll down there I will keep it the
same one minute uh
bid ask for delta type
you don't need tick replay on their
chart on my chart you do that's one of
the differences and you can see down
here uh volumetric chart type name
volumetrics keep it the same bid ask
I'll just open up a bit ask chart
and we'll open it up real quick whoops
hit OK not cancel and there you go Okay
so
obviously you're going to have to play
around with it a bit to get it the way
you want so let's take a look at some of
the things here so this is your
footprint right your basic one now of
course you can
um
customize it so you go into again back
into the data series and you're going to
scroll down here this is where you're
going to find a lot of these settings
down in here all right so let's go back
here so maybe you don't want the bar on
the edge okay maybe you want it in the
middle you're going to hit Center open
close bar
all right click apply right now it's in
the middle
um you know you can show a profile
right of the volume and that's the Delta
profile I would guess
or actually now it's just a regular
volume profile you can sort of see it in
here now this has always been a big
bone of contention for me I don't know
why a lot of these trading softwares
love having the black background okay I
know Bloomberg obviously is you know
I've used Bloomberg for 30 years it's
got a black background I think you know
they're trying to look more professional
like Bloomberg but when you read a book
it's not black paper it's white paper
with with black text right that's why
when you see my software right you see
it running
right it's white background with
black text I I think that's I personally
I that's me I think it's just easier to
uh pick things up especially you know
with the black background you know when
you're looking at coloring things in
um
you know they sort of blend into the
back a lot easier than if you're looking
at a white background but again hey
that's just me what do I know
um
okay let's go back to these settings in
here so
again I prefer the candle in the middle
I just find it a lot easier so let's
open this up see what else we got in
here
okay so you can show the profile I don't
know what the sensitivity is the display
size filter say you just want to see uh
price levels that have more than a
certain volume you know I don't know
call it 250 right this is e-mini one
minute chart that's what it would look
like right you're seeing these levels in
there I don't have that on mine I don't
think that's I just never found any
value in that I could be completely
wrong
um let's go back here now imbalances
okay
you're going to check that there's two
faults at 1.5
um which is pretty not much you know me
personally I think you should use at
least four as low as that goes probably
about three because to be honest at 1.5
you're gonna get a ton of
imbalances all right I mean that's not
much of an imbalance I mean it's it's
greater than one I guess but you know
you want something that
makes a statements right that leaves no
question
in your mind that this is an imbalance
it's more than double it's double double
it's four to one
and you're going to look at it
diagonally what's the other choices you
got diagonal horizontal and that's
interesting horizontal but uh keep it
diagonal so you're going to see here the
imbalance is 105 against 16 29 against
127 looks like the uh buying imbalances
are colored
blue for buying red for
selling or magenta cyan and magenta
colors
okay maybe there's a way to adjust it I
don't know why this one's showing up as
uh
yellow
uh I think I think that's what they're
doing here is because I don't see a
setting in here for
yeah here it is show maximum and see
what that is take that off right yeah
show their show maximum is actually
their point of control okay and it's
coloring it it's coloring the volumes a
certain levels so for example
you know or yellow okay
that's why you see 127 290 so you're not
even seeing this imbalance because it's
already coloring
the price levels or the volumes yellow
so it's overriding that imbalance
because you have the pointed controller
that is I guess their point of control
um interesting okay so let's just go
back up here so
minimum Delta for imbalance 10 okay I
think you need that because you don't
want to be looking at an imbalance of
one against four especially if you have
if you're using their default of 1.5
um you know if you got uh one against
three you'd have an imbalance so yeah
color dominant side what does that look
like
well again on a black background it's
nearly impossible to see that's why I
think you should use a white background
all right so they got color body
candle outline
this color
if that's fine I guess you can't even
change it
um solid whites I guess that's this one
going around there College green color
for down bars red black for doji which
kind of makes no sense if you got a
black background
um and you're calling the bar black
all right I can see it see if there's
any dojis in here I guess I wouldn't see
it because it's colored black right
um
well this is
okay here's a doji candle it's called it
black yeah I guess you can't see because
it's outline is uh outline is white
okay fair enough
um let's take a look at some of these
other settings in here okay so where was
I call her for doji box outline or box
grid yeah here so
yes that's the transparent see what
happens
nothing it doesn't actually change so
I'm not sure what their box grid is I
would have thought it's like sort of
this box you can sort of barely see it
there
uh maybe that's this box outline maybe
change that to
transparent
okay so that box around the bar is gone
okay so that's what that is uh color for
positive strength green color for
negative strength buying a balance here
is the colors are cyan and magenta the
show maximum right is the that point of
control right let's see I take it off
then you see your imbalances coming in
um personally I think they should adjust
that here oops take this off here
okay uh put that back on just so I know
where that is I mean if you got an
imbalance like sort of in the middle and
it's coming in with the point of control
I'd like to know that rather than you
know you might miss it honestly
uh High text I don't know what that is
let's see what was hiding okay so that's
the volumes yeah I mean you know some
people they like to look at sort of a
volume profile like that okay I can
grasp that I guess
um show bar statistics okay let's take a
look what we're going to see down here
hit apply
okay so it's going to be down here
trades volume by volume cell volume
Delta in a bar Delta percentage
cumulative Delta Max Min Delta we got a
couple more Delta change Delta sh Delta
SL
okay
um
you can't adjust the size from in here
color for bass
color for bases
Ace of Base uh let me just mix let me
just play around with colors see what
changes if anything uh let's
right now it's like yellow okay I'll
change it to
in indigo
looks like something I don't know I'll
say I don't know what that one is for
I'd have to mess around with it a little
bit deeper again I don't use their soft
I don't use their uh yeah it's this one
color for the base so whatever you know
the background of these collars are
statistic grid color
okay that's the grid of this statistics
on the bottom and I think that's it okay
now one thing right if you want to
go in and change some of this stuff
you'd have to go to properties I still
say I want to make the fonts bigger
right like the Axis or the stuff here on
the side
um going to the Chart properties change
it from 11 to something bigger 16 right
hit apply so obviously it's much bigger
chart background if I were to change it
from black I'm kind of curious if I go
to White
okay now I'd have to change the text
color Sometimes some way
uh maybe change that to Black see what
comes up okay well that's this text here
um
that's the text on the side obviously uh
crosshairs
axis
let's change that to Black
okay so there
um grid line horizontal that's the grids
that are appearing on here I don't know
why you can't change it from inside
there but let me just change these two
transparent that should clear up
and it looked like an Excel spreadsheet
I just wanted to figure out how I could
change the colors
of the numbers
okay because you know I can't read it if
it's white default is white
um it's not going to be very useful to
me uh
just looking through here
I don't see anything for text in here
I'll hear color for text
let me do that one change that to Black
okay there you go so yeah it's a little
easier to read
and again you can play around with some
of these colors I I just wish that if
you're going to use color for maximum
then you'd probably
you know want to use something
you're not gonna well I mean I guess you
could use something dark like a dark
blue
okay here I wish you had a choice to
make it bold or something or just put a
box around just something that would
just really grab your attention
because you'd really need a color
I guess you know I guess it's not
optimized for a white background I mean
I mean maybe you could play around with
it a bit more
sort of figure it out but I mean as a
basic footprint I mean it's it's
manageable it's workable you could
figure out that yeah I mean the area
where the blue is obviously you know in
this case I changed it to Blue from
yellow
um is your is your colors
now
my order flow footprint chart
okay you can see here I I think it's a
lot easier to read
right red for selling imbalances blue
for buying and balances point of control
is clearly marked all right so for
example let's go here right
you can see
let's compare
let me uh let's do this here I'll
move to a new window here okay
sort of compare it side by side
now let's go back to an e-mini E mini
chart here
okay and I'll just
do this
Okay so
you know here you got your
point of control 177 against 247 here
it's your point of controls coming in
there see the one okay the 119.
um you know the 0 to 35 up here 87. yeah
here you can put the profile on there
yeah okay
[Music]
um
I I I do use point of controls a lot and
I just don't like that you don't have
that point of control option on here
maybe there is I'm just not seeing it
maybe they're watching my videos I have
a feeling they do watch my videos maybe
they could take this and build off of it
put some other things in there but this
watch this okay
you know on my oracles Trader software
which sits on ninjatrader right this is
why people say well I don't go spend
money on your software when I could get
it on ninjatrader for free yeah this is
your basic footprint here so this is
where it takes it much further okay
Prominent Point of controls okay just
looking at Prominent Point of controls
here
okay I'm gonna draw them out until
tested let's add those on here
give it a second to come up here
and
look at this I if you don't think
something like Prominent Point controls
are important this is where we're
trading right now here right now right
it's what time is it it's 2 45 in the
afternoon Prominent Point of control
primary point of control three Prominent
Point controls right at the same level
you would never notice that
on this chart
well first of all it's hard to notice if
there's a point of control here you'd
sort of have to guess that
but you got Prominent Point of control
it's drawn out this line because it's
not trading back into it got another
primary point of control another
Prominent Point of control and the
market rally right and if you don't
think Prominent Point controls
are that important let's just sort of go
back here this is just one of the tools
that's on my software here here's a
bearish pound important control you see
the line being drawn out it had a nice
sell-off from there
okay there's another bullish problem at
a point of control a nice Rally from
there here's one it started to go up and
came down stop God okay fine got another
bullish Prominent Point of control here
a nice rally going up even earlier I
remember at the low of the day initially
in the morning
all right right in here same thing two
bullish permanent point of controls at
that same level
one minute before the cash opened
another one minute
three minutes after the cash open a nice
rally where the market sell off to it
sold off right to that Prominent Point
of control
other than it bounced and rallied up
right but you don't even have pointed
controls on there on their chart which
blows my mind
um
what else I mean that's just one of our
tools right maybe you want to analyze
um
you know we'll call it we'll just do the
exhaustion prints okay
change that because it's all tested I'll
shut off
for now I'll just disable the Prominent
Point of control so you're not confused
but you know we've got a few point of
control things on here we'll look at the
exhaustion Prince of
nine
okay
exhaustion for an exhaustion print
exhaustion print bullish one bullish one
bullish will and bearish
on here you'd have to manage
what you're seeing and make note of it
or is on the oracle's trader it's
highlighted to you okay what about some
Delta tools
let's take a look here
okay let's turn off the exhaustion
prints well
just a basic thing a very important
thing in order flow
stacking balances let's talk about that
real quick
on
here
I don't think it even highlights stacked
imbalances I mean if there is a setting
report I'll say I don't know where it is
on here I I yet to find it
you know in there you know here they got
okay with the Delta Market depth map
trade detector volume profile blah blah
blah but
they don't even have a basic thing of
stacked
um
stack imbalances are there even any
stacked imbalances today I don't know
so what we've seen is why we don't have
it
it's not important but you know in some
markets
okay
which I got it turned on right I I was
clicking my charts really quick here uh
yeah stack and balance three
back
you know here right this was yesterday
and this nice stacked and balancing how
the market rallied up from that
right stacked in Balance here stacked
and balanced area remember yesterday we
had a lot of stacked imbalances up and
down
um
one big one very early
right here yesterday
that's just a basic thing I mean it's
not even on they're volumetric I mean if
you guys are hearing the ninja ninja
Trader add these things in there for the
love of God help
I hope their Traders out
um you know
what else I mean Delta right I mean
we've got tools to analyze Market
weakness by looking at the delta
uh
uh Market weakness let's take a look
here
these are all built into my footprint my
order closed Trader footprint
okay so you know people always asking
what's the difference between yours and
and the one I can get for free on
ninjatrader well
the ninjatrader one is a basic footprint
chart if you think you've got the skills
to analyze this then yes you don't need
my software but if you want to get a leg
up right let the software do some of the
analysis for you here's a little Delta
weakness there but uh you know right
here
uh there's one there but you know
there's a beautiful one here at 11 this
morning
um you know with a nice move up you'll
get another one up here so
now even value areas to me value areas
are very important
um understanding where the market is
trading around value
I'll make that change that so until
tested value errors I've even got two
settings I got value areas and engulfing
value areas
now on
ninja the volumetric charts again if you
have the paid version of ninja
Trader if you go into the settings of
they do have in there I'll give them
this much uh volume profile okay and you
could do it by bars
okay so example I'm on a one minute
volumetric chart I guess I could put it
on here
oh how it's
plotting on here
looks like it's offset by a bar honestly
if I have to change the offset on that
because it's
all right
where is it here for level resolution
bar I know what it's doing it's putting
here
right so for example here go back
what it's doing
is it's plotting
the profile one bar out so even though
the current bar is trading right here
this profile
you can't see my crosshairs let me just
make this crosshairs a little bit easier
to see
change this to a white background but
let me just make it bigger
so what it's doing is actually printing
out so for example this bar here right
this big candle here
it's putting its profile here
okay
and I guess the one nice thing is this
one does have the point of control right
this yellow area is that bars
oh point of control I guess
it's hard to tell even though
it's just not giving me some good
information here
hard to tell with this it's very
overlapping
but you know anyway you you get the idea
right so there's differences in the
footprints right value areas
value areas I mean there's ways you
could sort of Cobble it together
on the Ninja
Trader volumetric chart and their order
flow tools
so again you know I I
created we me I just want to say I you
know it's the Royal eye me and my my
programmer I got to give him a lot of
credit because he's a hard worker and he
understands what I need when I explain
it to him
um all these tools that we have in the
order flows Trader software are there
for a reason
right and they've been copied by other
software vendors out there
find whatever but at the end of the day
they're not the originator of it so they
don't always teach it the right way that
it's supposed to be in my opinion
utilized
but anyway guys I I'm not trying to put
down the volumetric charts I mean it's
useful for Traders that will want to get
into order flow don't get me wrong you
know I I support every tool but you know
I do get this question a lot is what's
the difference between
my software which sits on ninjatrader
and the one that's available on the paid
version of ninjatrader okay so I hope
that sort of helps you understand but
again we've got a lot of tools on here
that's not available in the volumetric
chart so for example right we've got
buying and selling tells Delta
Divergence exhaustion prints and balance
reversals inverse volume and balance
Market sweep detector Market weakness
detector order flow sequencing ratios
PLC slingshot prominent opponent
controls stacked and balance thin prints
value areas zero prints
ladder contents of course
um unfinished business you've got volume
imbalances you've even got the volume
profile if you need it but you know we
got a lot of tools that we put in there
right ours is an add-on for ninjatrader
right it's not going to replace ninja
you still need a ninja Trader to run our
software
so I hope that answers your questions
out there for everyone that has been
asking me
um you know what's the differences
between order post Trader
you know because if you're going to get
the paid version of ninjatrader I don't
know what it costs now
1400 bucks or something then my software
which is an additional cost
of like 750 you know people like why do
I gotta spend that when I I've already
have it well this is the differences
okay
it's like why should I put
uh I don't know how this is how to
compare it you know you're it's an
add-on basically you know it's just like
if you understand anything about high
performance cars
right you can get your engines modified
right to make it perform better
mine is
that modification to make your
chart perform better so to speak anyway
I hope that answers you guys questions
and again if you're interested in the
software the link is below
um
but you know oracle is very robust
there's a lot of information in the
footprints
but as a Trader you need to understand
what it is you're looking at and that's
why
the workforce Trader helps Traders
understand exactly what they're looking
at all right everyone have a great day
and I'll see you guys on the next video
bye bye